this was the moment security cameras
captured the attack at the busy street
food bar number one Cafe in the heart of
Saint Petersburg on Sunday
the explosion killed 40 year old
military blogger vladolin tatarsky who
was delivering a speech at the event
organized by The cyberfront Zed movement
an association of people with patriotic
views
they hold talks at this Cafe every week
over 100 people were in and around this
event at the time of the attack
the donbass native was given the statue
of himself as a gift moments before the
blast
according to the mayor of Saint
Petersburg all the city's Emergency
Services have been called in to deal
with the incident
labelin tatarski launched his own social
media channel to report on the
activities of the Russian military in
its so-called special military operation
and has a following of over 500 000
subscribers tatarsky was invited to the
lavish ceremony last September at the
Kremlin where Russian president
proclaimed the annexation of four
regions of Ukraine
was a well-known figure among Kremlin
supporters seen here with Daria duginao
who was killed in a car bomb attack last
August in Moscow region her father
Alexander Dugan a far-right political
philosopher and Kremlin supporter was
believed to be the intended target the
Russian foreign Ministry has issued a
statement condemning the attack and
praising tatarski's work as a journalist
and his service to his country these
types of attacks are rare in Russia but
the planning and plotting behind them
just prove that the battles are not
confined to the dumbass region
Moscow